DOWN.
CORRESPONDENT GRIFF JENKINS HAS
BEEN THERE ALL DAY.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THIS APPEARS TO BE A CASE OF A
SYSTEM WORKING RIGHT.
SHERIFF CAMERON SAYS THE MOTIVE
ISN'T CLEAR JUST QUITE YET, BUT
HE PAINTED A PICTURE OF A PRIOR
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DECEASED GUNMEN, AUSTIN WYATT
RAWLINS, HE 17, AND A FEMALE
STUDENT WHO IS 16.
SHE IS IN INTENSIVE CARE AT A
LOCAL HOSPITAL AT THIS HOUR,
FIGHTING FOR HER LIFE.
THE SECOND SHOOTING VICTIM, A
14-YEAR-OLD MALE STUDENT, IS IN
STABLE CONDITION.
THE SHERIFF DETAILING HOW THIS
ALL UNFOLDED EARLIER TODAY AND
THE BRAVE ACTIONS OF THAT SCHOOL
RESOURCES OFFICER, DEPUTY
SHERIFF BLAINE GASKILL.
>> DFC BLAINE GASKILL FIRED AT
THAT SHOOTER AND WHAT IS
DESCRIBED TO ME ALMOST SIMON
SIMULTANEOUSLY, THE SHOOTER
FIRED.
>> NOW, BLAINE GASKILL SAYS IT
WILL BE FURTHER INVESTIGATION TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS
HIS SHOT THAT KILLED THE GUNMAN.
THE FACT REMAINS, BRET, THAT YET
AGAIN, WE'VE HAD SOMEONE OPEN
FIRE IN ONE OF OUR SCHOOLS IN
2018, AND MARYLAND'S GOVERNOR,
LARRY HOGAN, SAYS HE IS OUTRAGED
THAT MORE ISN'T BEING DONE.
>> NO PARENT SHOULD EVER HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT WHEN THEY SEND THEIR
KIDS OFF IN THE MORNING TO
SCHOOL WHETHER THEY WILL COME
HOME SAFELY OR NOT.
AND WE NEED MORE THAN PRAYERS.
I WANT TO THINK THESE
FIRST RESPONDERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS FOR THE JOB
THEY DID BUT WE NEED MORE.
WE NEED TO TAKE ACTION.
>> JUST FOR A LITTLE CONTEXT, IT
WAS ONE WEEK AGO TOMORROW THAT
THE STUDENTS HERE AT GREAT MILLS
HIGH SCHOOL BEHIND ME WALKED OUT